problem a hundred so they draw this
graph which I guess I should also draw
so they drop pretty big so I'll draw it
pretty big as well let's see if I can so
they have a line that goes from the
center to there it's a pie graph and
they call that categories like that
another category that looks something
like that and then they have a final
category looks something like that and
they say that this is the highway
highway trust fund which is 72% they say
X percent is a tire tax tire tax this is
12% which is a gas tax gas tax and then
you have X plus 4% X plus 4% which is a
tax on trucks tax on trucks according to
the graph above what percent of the
funds for highway maintenance oh and
this title says sources of funds for
highway maintenance okay so that's what
this whole thing is according to the
graph above what percent of the funds
for highway maintenance came from the
tax on tires tax on tires okay so we
need to solve for X so let's think about
it X X plus 12 plus X plus 4 right
that's this plus 70 to have to equal 100
percent
right let's see we have 2 X's so if 2
X's goes out of the way and then what is
this equal to 12 plus 4 is 16 all right
12 plus 4 is 16 16 plus 72 let me write
that down
I always make careless mistakes that's
16 16 plus 72 is 88 2x plus 88 it is
equal to 100 and then you have 2x is
equal to subtract 8 from both sides 12 X
is equal to 6 and that's exactly what
we're looking for the tire tax so it's
at 6% and that's choice B be drawing it
was harder than solving it
problem 101 a poll reveals that the
average arithmetic mean income of ten
households is $225,000 okay so we could
say average of 10 is equal to 25 okay if
six of the households have income of
30,000 what is the average of the other
four households okay so if we were if we
were to average all of them we could say
it would be six times the households
that are 30,000 so 6 times 30 K plus 4
times the average of the other four so
let's say that's what we're trying to
solve for four times the average of the
other four households and this would be
the sum of all of the households and if
we divide though that by 10 we're gonna
get the total average of all 10 which is
25 hopeful that makes sense right
you have six households making 30k so
the sum of those households gonna be six
times 30 and then the sum of the other
four households is going to be four
times their average and that's what they
are asking us for what is the average
income so this is sum of all the
households if you take the sum of all
the households all ten you divide it by
10 you get their average so you get 6
times 30 this is I don't wanna make this
look like a variable as 30,000 we know
we're dealing in thousands so 6 times 30
is 180 plus 4x is equal to 10 times 25
is equal to 250 all right
4x is equal to what's to 250 divide -
180 is 15 other 20 it's equal to 70 and
then you have X is equal to let's see 4
goes into 70 130 goes into it 7 and 7
times 4 is 28 those up to 25 times as
decimal so 17.5 and we're dealing with
thousands so $17,500 and that's choice C
problem 102 102 if T is equal to
is equal to 5/9 times K minus 32 and T
is equal to 290 then what is k equal do
this is kind of one of those speed
problems so we have 290 is equal to 5/9
times K minus 32 so multiply both sides
by 9/5 so you get 9 over 5 times 290 is
equal to K minus 32 so let's - 90
divided by 5 see 5 goes into 290 sin 5
goes into 29 5 times 25 40 58 times so
it's 9 times 58 is equal to K minus 32
see 58 times 9 8 times 9 is 72 5 times 9
is 45 plus 7 it's 52 522 so 522 is equal
to K minus 32 so K is equal to 5 22 plus
32 which is equal to 554 which is choice
D after doing all that math I was afraid
that I'd made a careless mistake but
it's it's reassuring to see that 554 is
one of the choices problem 103 problem
103 the water from one outlet flowing at
a constant rate can fill a swimming pool
in 9 hours so you could say one pool for
nine hours from one outlet the water
from a second outlet flowing at a
constant rate can fill the same pool in
five hours so one pool in five hours
that's the second one if both outlets
are used at the same time approximately
what is the number of hours required to
fill the pool so essentially we we can
just add their two rates right this one
does 1/9 pool per hour
Poole per hour plus 1/5 Poole per hour I
just rewrote those two so what's 1/9
plus 1/5 let's find a common denominator
that's 45 I think it's the first common
denominator 1/9 is 5 over 45 1/5 is 9
over 45 so together they fill 5 plus 9
is 14 40 fifths pool per hour right and
if you want to if you want to fill
exactly one pool right so it's just like
you know production is equal to rate
times time so now your production is you
want to fill one pool and you can fill
it at 14 over 45 pools per hour pools
per hour what is the time well the time
is going to be equal to 1 over 1 pool
divided by 14 over 45 pools per hour
which is equal to 45 over 14 right 1
over a fraction is just the universe of
that fraction is equal to 45 over 14
hours and how many times does 14 go into
45 14 goes into 45 3 times 3 times 14 is
12 it's 42 then you have another 30 then
you have well I already see one of the
choices is 3 point something but 14 goes
into 32 times 2 times 14 is 28 let's see
if one of our choices already yeah
choice D is already close enough to what
we do we'd have to do anymore math so we
get three point two hours and if we kept
dividing we'd get three point two one
and that's choice D it's just a little
confusing and the important thing is to
always get it in terms of rates add the
rates and this remember you know
distance is equal to rate times time or
production is equal to rate times time
and don't let it big you know that all
these fractions taught you too much next
problem almost out of space problem 104
dianna bought a stereo for five hundred
and thirty dollars which was the retail
price plus a six percent sales tax
so that is equal to 1.0 six times the
retail right 6% more than the retail how
much could she has saved if she had
bought the stereo at the same retail
price in a neighboring state where she
would have paid a sales tax of 5% okay
so essentially we want to figure out we
want to figure out yeah how much would
she have saved all right so let's figure
out what the what the retail price was
so retail is equal to five thirty
divided by 1.06 1.06 goes into five
hundred and thirty it's a decimal at two
zeroes shift the decimal over to the
right twice 106 goes into Phi I think it
goes into it what five times right 106
goes into five 35 times five five times
106 five times 106 it's five times yeah
it's five thirty
okay so the math you was simple so you
have two zeros so the retail price is
five dollars
the retail price is five dollars a $500
sorry five hundred dollars she paid five
two so she paid thirty dollars in tax
fair enough if she went to the other the
neighboring state and paid five percent
well how much would if she have paid in
taxes so times 0.05 five times 5 well 5
times 500 is two thousand five hundred
plus two decimals is twenty-five dollars
in tax so the neighboring states she
would have paid twenty-five dollars in
taxes she paid thirty dollars in taxes
so she would have saved five dollars so
the choice is d the choice is d let's
just try to fit one more problem in here
just so we finished this page so say if
a square mirror has a 20 inch diagonal
what was the approximate perimeter of
the mirror and inches let's try to do
that so we have a square well that's not
what I wanted it to do I have a square
mirror it has a diagonal
it has a diagonal and that diagonal
they're telling us is 20 inches it's a
square so all the sides are the same
right and they want to know its
perimeter so they want to know
essentially what 4x is equal to right if
we add up all the sides so what is X Y
well we just use Pythagorean theorem
this is a right angle so we know that x
squared plus x squared x squared plus x
squared is equal to 20 squared is equal
to the hypotenuse squared is equal to
400 2x squared is equal to 400 x squared
is equal to 200 X is equal to the square
root of 200 and they want to know the
perimeter what's going to be 4 times
that so the perimeter is going to be
equal to 4 times the square root of 200
and now this becomes a approximation
problem so let's think about that the
square root of 200 is the C square root
of it's about 15 right 15 times 15 is
225 all right yeah I think 15 would be a
pretty good approximation 14 would also
work 14 square square it is 196 right 14
times 14 4 times 16 it's 56 and then you
have 140 so you have 14 is about as
close as you're gonna get to 200 so
what's fort it's gonna be someplace
between 14 and 15 so 14 times 4 is 40 so
4 times 4 is 16 it's 56 so it's going to
be something higher than 56 if we pick
14 as 56 if we pick 15 at 60 so
someplace between 56 and 60 is going to
be the perimeter of that mirror and so
it's one of the choices is be 60 and so
that's going to be the closest one so
I'd go with B I'll see you in the next
video